[Musique]
bienvenue dans pôle it mag aujourd'hui
on va parler du malaise dans l'hôpital
public et des déserts médicaux en pleine
crise du coronavirus on en parle avec
nos invités sur ce plateau laurent
lisbonne ce qui aide soignant à
l'hôpital tenon et membre du collectif
interurbain gensse face avoue frédéric
bizarre économiste de la santé et jean
bernard gervais rédacteur en chef du
magazine en ligne
what's up doc merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation sur rt france le
ministre de la santé vient de déclencher
le plan blanc dans tous les hôpitaux de
france
un dispositif d'urgence dans un contexte
de service public médical en crise
depuis des mois avec un phénomène de
déserts médicaux qui ne fait que
s'accentuer
illustration en ile-de-france premier
dm4 français alors que la région est la
plus riche et la plus peuplée du pays
voyez ce reportage de solenn gaudin
lionel girard et laurent portes
prendre un rendez vous avec un médecin
un véritable casse tête pour les
franciliens
en ile-de-france la population a accès à
moins de 2,5 consultations par an par
habitant
c'est deux fois moins que la moyenne
nationale un problème qui en entraîne un
autre
l'engorgement des hôpitaux et surtout d
urgence les agences ou encombrés par des
malades qui viennent directement parce
qu'ils ont plus de médecins généralistes
et aujourd'hui il ya des médecins qui
partent parce qu'ils ont une telle
pression de continuité des soins sur
l'hôpital qui peuvent pas tenir jeu
contient un service où il y aurait
besoin de quatre ou cinq médecins et
qu'on met un poste qui va le prendre
cela pour se taper le tu n'habites
malades personne et j'ai des collègues
qui baisse les bras je peux vous dire
parce qu'ils savent très bien que les
malades sont pas soignés correctement
alors pour stopper l'hémorragie
certaines communes prennent le relais à
ce temps la mairie finance un centre
municipal de santé qui emploie 35
praticiens 30000 actes médicaux ils sont
pratiqués chaque année des conditions de
travail et de soins plus confortable qui
permet un suivi régulier des patients
on peut s'attarder un petit peu plus sur
le côté psychologique sur le côté
relationnel et ne pas simplement faire
les actes de soins comme comme à
l'hôpital et a beaucoup de personnes
âgées
du coup elle préfère se déplacer ici il
ya des habitués donc il connaît ce sens
de santé depuis plusieurs années
mais une initiative qui a un coût élevé
pour cette commune de 40000 habitants 3
millions d'euros par an et un centre de
soins qui peinent aussi à recruter le
manque de médecins
je pense moi je l'expliquent par le
numerus clausus 6 en moins de médecins
dans qu'il ya moins de prescriptions qui
dit moins de prescriptions 20 des
dépenses
donc je pense qu'il faut enlever quand
même le numerus clausus et
[Applaudissements]
voilà libéré un peu la messi le numerus
clausus sera supprimée à partir de la
rentrée 2020 mais il faudra encore
attendre que cette nouvelle génération
de médecins soient formés au total les
études de médecine dure neuf ans bref
frédéric à blizzard il ya plus de 4
millions de franciliens qui n'ont pas
accès un généraliste comme il le devrait
alors qu'il y a beaucoup de médecins en
ile de france
comment est ce qu'on explique ce
paradoxe les déserts médicaux c'est pas
simplement les zones rurales comme on
peut le penser
non alors je crois que comme en médecine
il faut avoir un bon diagnostic pour
avoir un bon traitement faut quand même
un petit peu s'attarder un peu sur le
diagnostic la france a été d'abord un
des pays qui a le mieux réussi
l'accès la médicalisation des
territoires au 20e siècle
c'est pour ça qu'on a été de en 2000 on
a eu le titre de meilleurs systèmes de
santé du monde c'est principalement
parce qu'on avait le mieux réussi c'est
pas le cas de tous les pays développés
alors comment comment se fait-il que
aujourd'hui on est un vrai problème
désertification médicale
c'est camille aux politiques publiques
qui ont été menées depuis 30 ans puisque
encore une fois on a réussi donc c'est
pas une problème de statut hôpital
public exercice libéral sait bien qu'il
ya eu des politiques publiques qui ont
été menées qui ont échoué
la première la première erreur qui a été
fait c'est dans les années 80 ça a été
dit dans votre reportage c'est qu'on a
juste diminuer par deux le nombre de
d'étudiants qui allait être fort mais
bon ça ce fameux numerus clausus le
problème ce n'est pas le numerus clausus
et là c'est la façon dont vous
l'utilisez on est passé à peu près de
8500 à 3000 dans les années 85 à 2000
bon il est clair que là on est en plein
en pleine conséquences de cette gestion
des mioches le suspens ensuite il ya eu
des lois qui ont été passés ça a démarré
par l' ordonnance de monsieur juppé et
depuis on n'a pas arrêté assure
administrer le système on a créé les
agences
parce que pourquoi est ce qu'on la fin
c'est que les pouvoirs publics penser
que plus on a les administrés le système
plus on allait contrôler la dépense sur
le rang des rentes à mais c'est exact
enfin pour mieux maîtriser la dépense
pas forcé par le rendement est en fait
celle inverse qui se pose d'abord on a
en effet décourager plutôt les soignants
qui ont quand même sont des gens qui ont
qui sont hautement qualifiés qui sont
hautement responsable et on a dit
notamment en 2009 avec la loi bachelot
on a dit écoutez maintenant il y aura
qu'un seul chef ça va être le
l'administratif donc on va mettre le
soignant sous la coupe de
l'administratif donc on a une gestion
purement comptable des hôpitaux mais
aussi de la médecine de ville qui fait
qu'on arrive aujourd'hui
1 alors on manque pas tu sais pas qu'on
manque de ressources et surtout qu'au
manque d'attractivité des ressources a
été très bien dans votre reporter les
ressources sont absolument épuisé
ils auront un liberski vous êtes vous
mêmes aides soignants au quotidien vous
êtes et soignant à l'hôpital tenon à
paris
au quotidien comment ça se traduit cette
surcharge de travail pour vous on peut
le voir quand même qu aux urgences
beaucoup de gens viennent pour diverses
raisons mais on voit que l'absence de
médecin traitant s'intensifie de jour en
jour pour plusieurs raisons il ya des
médecins généralistes qui partent à la
retraite qui ne sont pas remplacés
c'est une raison majeure en
ile-de-france effectivement de cette
désertification tout à fait tout à fait
comme vous l'avez très bien dit ce
numerus clausus c'est quelque chose qui
n'efface quand même il faut c'est
quelque chose qui fait que moins de
médecins pour plus de personnes et les
gens deviennent de plus en plus âgés
pleurer pathologique donne forcément il
ya de plus en plus de demandes de soins
à côté de ça il ya une diminution de
l'offre de soins à côté de ça des
diminutions de l'offre de santé
je pense que ça participe beaucoup vous
même comment vous le ressentez en tant
qu'aide soignant le fait de ne pas aller
au bout de votre mission finalement
comment est-ce que ça se vit au
quotidien
au quotidien on est surmené dépassé par
par la demande de soins et par
l'augmentation de ça veut dire aller
plus vite aller plus vite et aussi le
faire moins bien
du coup pour pour le personnel
paramédical et médical aussi jean
bernard gervais on parler de ce fameux
numerus clausus qui a sauté un qui n'est
plus en vigueur est à peu près de 9000
médecins qui sont qui sont formés en
france sauf que pour avoir des effets
retour d'effets bénéfiques finalement il
va falloir attendre encore des années
puisqu'il faut à peu près dix ans pour
former un médecin
c'est quoi alors qu'il ya urgence
aujourd'hui pour sauver l'hôpital public
c'est ça oui il va falloir attendre une
dizaine d'années avant fait de devoir
former une nouvelle génération de
médecins alors j'ajoute aussi en fait
que si le numerus clausus a été supprimé
ça veut pas dire pour autant en fait que
la sélection dans les études de médecine
ne sera supprimée on peut en fait
remplacer une sélection par une autre et
je pensais d'ailleurs en fait les
syndicats d'un terne ont peur en effet
que ce numerus clausus soit remplacée
par une autre forme de sélection
première chose alors concernant en fait
l'effet des airs médical je tiens quand
même à rappeler que la france mais comme
le disait en fait mathieu bizarre
s'inscrire à peu près dans la moyenne en
fait de l' ocde je crois qu'on est à 3,4
ou 3,5 km sa part pour 1000 habitants
donc c'est pas non plus en fait
catastrophique je pense qu'on a plutôt
en fait à faire là actuellement une
crise de la répartition des médecins
si on prend par exemple intra muros
paris intra muros on a l'une des plus
forte densité médicale en france
seulement il ya des coins en effet comme
dans le 18ème 19ème 20ème la petite
ceinture etc ou là il ya vraiment des
déserts médicaux en première chose et
deuxième chose il ya un effet ciseau
aussi qu'il faut rappeler vous l'avez en
fait tout à leur dit c'est à dire qu'on
a affaire en fait un papy boom d'un papy
boom médical la génération en fait d'une
génération une génération était en train
de partir à la retraite entre 2007 et
2026 qu'on va perdre à peu près 25% des
médecins généralistes
donc on est en plein en fait dans le
papy-boom donc effet ciseau d'un côté en
effet restriction est passé en fait de
8000 à 4000 puis on est remonté en fait
à 8000 médecins formés via le numerus
clausus et puis de l'autre côté en fait
une baisse de 20 à 25% en fait des des
médecins qui partent à la retraite donc
manque d'effectif pourquoi est-ce qu'on
en est arrivé là voyez le constat de
jérôme marty il est président de l'union
française pour une médecine libre
regardez pourquoi et comment elle en est
arrivée là par une hyper administration
par le fait qu'on a coupé complètement
les mêmes qui soigne de tout processus
décisionnaire et que les sites
uniquement c'était cette fameuse
administration qui depuis des années des
années prend les décisions et respecte
une politique qui vise à faire ce qu'on
appelle de l'efficience vous savez ce
que c'est l'efficience et faire mieux
avec moins
or l'hôpital est déjà à loos donc on
voit pas comment il pourrait faire mieux
avec encore moins
cette politique est vouée à l'échec elle
brise
les autant les professionnels d'ailleurs
que les patients à terme elle épuise les
équipes
elle donne une perte de sens et elle
fait ce que l'on connaît c'est à dire
une espérance de vie professionnelle
pour les infirmières qui est de 8 ans
des suicides qui se multiplient des burn
out qui se multiplient des gens qui
quittent l'hôpital et des postes qui
restent vacants et donc un cercle
vicieux qui se crée avec ceux qui
restent qui doivent travailler en groupe
deux fois plus pour absorber le manque
frédéric buzare il ya longtemps il ya un
vrai malaise dans la profession
est-ce que c'est dû également au fait
que la médecine de ville
oui parler on parler d'un problème
d'administration c'est un problème de
gouvernance également c'est à l'hôpital
de gérer l'hôpital et non pas aux
administrations
alors il ya d'abord on est on fait face
à un changement considérable de
l'environnement c'est cette triple
transition démographique épidémiologique
donc par là monsieur on passe maintenant
la plateau logis chronique qui ont qui
sont une prise en charge très différente
de ce qu'on a connu au 20e siècle
et puis cette révolution technologique
qui est censé quand même apporter un
certain nombre de solutions et qu'on a
énormément de mal à rendre accessible et
à positiver et à permettre au système de
mieux fonctionner donc en effet face à
une crise systémique
vous n'avez qu'une refondation de
l'ensemble du système la seule chose
c'est que ce n'est pas à l'agenda
politique d'aucun parti politique a pas
un seul parti politique qui se
préoccupent de repenser à ces substances
c'est pourtant bien plus urgent que de
repenser le système de retraites même
s'il faut repenser l'ensemble des choses
je fais pas là mais je pense qu'il y
avait en effet aussi modifié de ces noël
est en tout cas là il ya vraiment une
urgence politique
bon alors évidemment cette crise
sanitaire qui vient au plus mauvais
moment à la fois sur un plan économique
mais aussi sur le plan sanitaire parce
qu'on a de telles tensions à l'hôpital
mais aussi dans les ehpad on pourrait
parler des ehpad sous-médicalisées sur
lequel cette soignant il ya vraiment un
épuisement des ressources paramédical
qui est absolument colossal donc je
dirais que dans toute crise yade et il
ya des opportunités
j'espère que il va y avoir une prise de
conscience parce que vous avez des
grèves à l'hôpital depuis près d'un an
et demi fait ste mans peut pas dire que
on est on est vu un petit peu un choc
sur le plan politique on dise là il ya
vraiment quelque chose de grave
scarlett soul et le plan ma santé 2022
qui comprend des choses intéressantes
mais qui est juste la continuité
c'est à dire qu'on pense qu'on va
arriver avec un stand de rustines avec
un certain nombre d'améliorations et
maintenant il faut prendre conscience
qu'il ya en effet sur le plan de vue de
la gouvernance sur le plan du
financement sur le plan de
l'organisation
il faut repenser le système il faut le
repenser comment il faut le repenser
d'abord en en faisant prendre conscience
qu'il ya un changement de paradigme
avant on s'occupait uniquement des gens
quand il était malade on avait une
stratégie d'accès aux soins
maintenant il faut avoir une stratégie
d'accès à la santé c'est à dire qu'il
faut considérer que le maintien en bonne
santé est aussi stratégique que la prise
en charge des soins pourquoi c'est pas
une volonté idéologique c'est parce que
dans ce vieillissement de la population
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé
devient une variable extrêmement
stratégique pour que le système soit
soutenable d'abord pour créer du
bien-être social pour réduire les
injustices sociales parce que je
rappelle les injustices sociales sont
surtout sur se maintient en bonne santé
ou voit tout le gradient des inégalités
s'exprimer parce que c'est pas si facile
que ça de rester en bonne santé et donc
il faut il faut qu'il ya un
investissement dans ce capital santé la
dent oui il ya toute cette partie là
qu'on peut appeler santé publique qui
est alors on a les ressources humaines
ainsi pour ça que moi je suis assez
optimiste que si on a la bonne stratégie
est la bonne refonte du système on peut
très vite rebondir et puis il ya en
matière de soins en effet à repenser le
site met alors à l'échelle des
territoires on sait qu'aujourd'hui là on
a une gouvernance très centralisé vous
savez que les hôpitaux sont va piloter à
l'échelle l'hôpital ils sont pilotés à
l'échelle de alors certains disent
beaucoup de bercy ils n'ont pas
totalement tort au moins à l'échelle de
de l'avenue de ségur c'est à dire du
ministère comment voulez-vous ou en 2020
qu'on est 6 e marty par les déficiences
mais quelque chose d'efficace si on va
par les déficiences avec cette
gouvernance qui est centralisé alors
qu'on sait qu'il faut piloter à
l'échelle du parcours du patient c'est
plus simplement le soins ponctuels qu'on
vous donne c'est le parcours des
patients chroniques patients chroniques
ces deux tiers des dépenses de santé
c'est 80% de la hausse des dépenses donc
déjà on a fait des choses on est on part
pas de rien en oncologie on a fait les
choses on a beaucoup travaillé il ya des
initiatives locales qui viennent des
initiatives
oui mais le problème c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup énormément de choses très bonne
mais il faut les rendre systémique il
faut que les appliquer à l'ensemble
comment on fait c'est pas avec à une
approche descendante politique qu'il
faut une réelle
politique non il faut une volonté
politique mais il faut mettre l'ensemble
des acteurs autour d'une table ce que
l'on va faire d'ailleurs au sein de la
santé conférence de consensus
parce que sinon vous n'y arriverez pas
juste un dernier mot on est encore sur
le modèle de 58 avec le temps plein
hospitalier avec avec une approche
hospital au centre et il faut à la fois
redonner à l'hôpital public sa place et
sa vraie place mais qui ne sera pas la
même place qu'au xxème siècle parce
qu'on sait qu'il faut faire ce virage
ambulatoire
donc oui il faut réussir la
transformation sans affaiblir ce qui a
fait vivre le succès cette vieille
public mais il faut réussir ce virage
ambulatoire avec l'ensemble de la
médecine de ville et l'ensemble des
professions paramédicales et on l'a vu
donc la mobilisation qui continue 1300
médecins qui ont collectivement décidé
de démissionner de leurs fonctions
administratives
récemment une ligne rouge a été franchie
voilà ce que ce que disent ces médecins
jean bernard gervais la charge
administrative des médecins c'est un
réel problème la charge administrative
des médecins est un réel problème et ce
qui pose réellement problème en tous les
cas à l'hôpital pour les médecins c'est
aussi la perte de sens on n'en a pas
parlé mais depuis en fait le début des
années 80 s'est mise en place une
réforme qu'on a appelé la tarification à
l'activité en kango pour simplifier les
choses
plus je fais d'actes et puis mon hôpital
en fait gagner de l'argent là c'est
vraiment assez d'actes rapporte plus je
sélectionne peut-être aussi des patients
c'est aussi oscillé une sélection des
patients et c'est là aussi nous l'une
des raisons mais vous avez peut-être
nous expliquer ça pour laquelle en fait
les personnes âgées restent dans les
couloirs en fait d urgence tout
simplement parce qu'elles rapportent
très peu d'argent et que personne n'en
veut dans les services
donc à une perte de sens qui est lié en
fait à la tarification à l activité il
ya en effet une suradministration que
l'on demande du fait en fait du codage
des actes et tout ça fait que les
médecins font de moins en moins de
médecine est de plus en plus en fait
d'administratifs et c'est la raison pour
laquelle d'ailleurs à côté en fait du
collectif interrogeant ce qui va fêter
son 1er année ça fait un an que des
urgentistes des soignants sont
actuellement en grève s'est mise en
place un collectif un terreau pitot qui
regroupe cette fois ci en fait des pas
seulement fait des soignants mais aussi
en fait des médecins lesquels ont décidé
en effet de démissionner en ce qu'on
parle de démission c'est toujours pareil
c'est un peu comme les grèves à
l'hôpital il n'y a pas vraiment grève
donc les missions sont pas vraiment des
démissions c'est juste que en effet ils
ne vont plus
satisfaire leurs missions administratif
alors ses médecins ont démissionné il ya
bientôt un mois de cela je crois
pour le moment il n'y a pas eu en fait d
co doit pas en fait il n'y a pas de
retour il y avait un changement de
ministre
entre-temps donc peut-être que ceci
explique cela on est en pleine crise du
cours des virus également justement
laurent libin ce qui le fait de laisser
sur le carreau si je puis dire prend
pour héros en tout cas des personnes
âgées
c'est le patient qui rapporte le plus
qui est finalement sélectionné
aujourd'hui les noms santé sa bien
entendu on peut le voir au quotidien
qu'est ce qu'ils rapportent ce sont les
soins qui sont lourds qui tout ce qu'il
y ait du quotidien les grosses
opérations
on voit que c'est quelque chose qui qui
fait vivre l'hôpital
tout ce qui est la radiologie aussi fait
bien vivre l'hôpital nous nos personnes
âgées elles sont complètement délaissé
c'est une personne âgée c'est des soins
de confort et d'aidé traitement par voie
orale
donc on leur donne c'est c'est pas
quelque chose qui est quantifiable pour
eux mais on a besoin de s'en occuper on
voit que lens om ça ne rapporte rien à
l'hôpital donc vous même vous vous dites
on va passer moins de temps avec ces
personnes là parce que finalement ils
rapportent peu alors non nous les
paramédicaux on passe du temps avec eux
mais leurs soins ne sont pas ne sont pas
bien notés comme comme on appelle ça
avec ce fameux tarif à l'activité ne
peut pas se permettre de passer à côté
de ces personnes là d'ailleurs voir déjà
qu'on les respecte mais en plus de ça ce
sont des patients comme les autres on va
écouter
emmanuel macron qui a été interpellé
récemment le 27 février dernier par un
médecin justement alors qu'il se rendait
à la pitié salpêtrière
lorsqu'il ya le premier mort dû
coronavirus écouter cet échange et les
personnels hospitaliers le corps
soignant qui dans son ensemble
après tous les efforts nécessaires nous
sommes au bout oui mais on a besoin d'un
choc avec bien les chocs donc à chocques
d'attractivité il faut absolument
refinancer en d'urgence mais c'est
extrêmement important
je suis pas là pour moi d'être comprise
et je suis là vous savez qui est
derrière moi l'ensemble du corps
soignant et on peut pas se contenter des
finalement je suis désolé mais moi non
d'accord mais on est passé par un haut
débit après on a fait constater
maintenant il faut agir dans leur cas
c'est beaucoup plus calme on va penser
alors moi le fond de ma pensée c'est que
kairos et le moment opportun et le
moment opportun pour le président la
république d'agir même dans une
situation dont il n'est pas responsable
c'est maintenant qu'il faut saisir et va
très bien
j'ai entendu je pense que je suis pas le
seul non ok
mon très bien ok je remercierai qu'un
autre hôpital
merci que vous pouvez le voir mais il a
un beau lui quand il a fallu sauver
notre dame il y avait beaucoup de monde
pour être élu là il faut sauver
l'hôpital public est en train de flamber
à la même vitesse que contre l'ama
failli flamber ça s'est joué à rien et
là en ce moment ça se joue à rien j'ai
pas d'autre chose à dire pour l'instant
je compte sur vous ah oui vous pourrez
compter sur nous
lambert sera moi reste à prouver voilà
pour cet appel frédéric bizarre un choc
d'attractivité le bon effort on sent on
sent vraiment le désarroi l'économie
demandé à l'hôpital chaque année ces 800
millions d'euros alors qu'il ya c'est
une somme considérable
les médecins demandent est ce que ce
soit complètement annulé c'est une des
pistes en tout cas refinancer en urgence
auprès d'al mais il faut voir le court
terme et le long terme et je pense qu'on
est il ya une co responsabilité de tous
les acteurs dans cette crise je pense
que on est en rejette la responsabilité
de choses sur l'état mais bon les taaf
et a pris des mesures qui ont été
accompagnés approuvé par les
institutions qui ont compris de
l'institution de soignants qui ont
accompagné donc mettons nous tous dans
cette responsabilité là la difficulté on
le voit avec monsieur macron je pense
que encore une fois et pour discuter
beaucoup avec des parlementaires des
responsables politiques il n'y a pas de
prise de conscience qu' on doit changer
de cap
d'accord il ya une crise mais parce que
si vous voulez son était gauche et
droite ont fait toutes les réformes
depuis 25 ans qui ont conduit en fait à
un système en effet sur administrés trop
centralisée on n'a pas fait les
transformations nécessaires on a
considéré qu'ils avaient pas cette
évolution la de changement de mon qu'on
passe du de légumes aux chroniques donc
regarder le modèle tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui
il n'est pas tellement différent d'il ya
40 ans on vit encore sur les ordonnances
de 1958 on n'a pas on a fait beaucoup de
d'adaptation mais pas de changement
structurel donc il ya du court terme et
alors ce qu'il ya quand même précipité
les choses
rien d'étonnant à ce qu'il arrive celui
ce qu'on a fait à l'hôpital on a investi
ces vingt dernières années
un plan hôpital 2007 j'ai un plan
hôpital humide mais pour faire quoi
simplement pour construire pour avoir
des hôpitaux cathédrale on sait qu'en
garde des modèles hospitalier ils sont
ils sont plutôt plus proche des villes
plus intégrés dans les villes plutôt de
plus petite taille
nous on a gardé ses grands hôpitaux les
a donc on a dépensé beaucoup d'argent
mais là où on a fait des économies
depuis dix ans c'est sur le personnel
hospitalier vous savez qu'on a quand
c'est que les quelque chose de ces
incroyables
on a pendant des années si on regardait
sur des dernières années joli le point
d'indicé à dire qu'on a dit écoutez
finalement vous allez perdre du pouvoir
d'achat
toute l'année mais bon c'est pour le
bien public vous allez enfin on est
étonné qu'après on est donc face aussi à
ce changement de management qui est
plutôt qui fait plutôt des qui est
plutôt d attractif pour le personnel
soignant vous y apportez une rigueur
budgétaire
et puis on a une rigueur aussi dans les
équipements quand vous regardez le
taudis rm pour prendre un exemple parmi
d'autres dans les hôpitaux on est bien
inférieur il ya quasiment deux fois
moins 10 rm que la moyenne des pays
européens
si vous regardez le développement des
nouvelles technologies de numérisation
des données vous avez toujours pas juste
pour prendre quelque chose de très
simple un dossier unique passion c'est à
dire que quand vous allez dans un
hôpital à et dans un hôpital b de la
même région
vous n'avez pas le même dossier unique
les connexions voyez on en est là
aujourd'hui
et donc il ya un moment où il faut
comprendre aussi que le personnel
soignant demanda donc pour conclure il
faut en effet il ya un plan
d'investissement mais qu'ils soient mis
sur les bonnes ressources sur les choses
qu à court terme pour redonner confiance
pour montrer vraiment que l'état a
compris et il faut un plan de
restructuration à long terme qu'ils
soient partagés par l'ensemble des
acteurs un plan de ressources dont on
parle des salaires évidemment on sait
que le france est très mal placée en
termes de salaires notamment pour ses
infirmières
dans classement dos et des oeufs on va
le voir à l'écran lors aux libyens ce
qui vous vous avez une prime puisque il
ya une prime qui a été octroyé par
l'état pour les personnels soignants qui
sont en ile-de-france en proche banlieue
en tout cas ils parient 66 euros de plus
par mois ça fait la différence alors
déjà ça fait pas vraiment la différence
dans un pronom points deuxième point
c'est suivant une gagne à l'année donc
si on gagne plus de x euros par an les
800 euros qui sont débloqués sinon c'est
deux fois moins donc ça veut dire que
des nouvelles infirmières ont gagné 66
euros mais des plus ancienne infirmière
ont gagné du coup l'équivalent d'une
trentaine d'euros par mois c'est ce
n'est pas ce qu'on demande c'est une
revue une vraie revalorisation pour tout
le personnel est que ce soit équivalent
pour tout le monde
c'est pour ça que le collectif
interrogeant se demandaient une
augmentation salariale de 300 euros par
mois ce qui représente est grosso modo
comme vous l'avez très bien dit le gel
du point d'indicé sur les dix dernières
années c'est l'équivalent est grosso
modo à 300 vaut donc c'était récupérer
ceux que nous avons perdus pendant dix
ans au niveau du personnel et ce qu'on
aimerait aussi c'est une une
augmentation du personnel
est ce que c'est bien plus attractif on
voit que si c'est pas attractive c'est
parce que déjà on ne gagne pas assez
d'argent mais en plus il n'y a pas assez
de bras pour s'occuper de tout ça de
tout de tout ce personnel s'il y avait
plus de monde forcément ils ont gagné
rendent l'attractivité parce que ça
serait plus intéressant on doit plus le
temps de bien s'occuper des gens voilà
ce qu'il en est actuellement il ya des
collectivités qui ont pris les devants
avant d'avoir des réponses du
gouvernement que vous attendez toujours
j'imagine
ce qui est des collectivités qui gèrent
et qui organise en tout cas des maisons
de santé pluridisciplinaires c'est la
solution pour essayer d'avoir des
spécialistes on l'a vu dans le reportage
de toutes disciplines dans un même
endroit pour essayer de revigorer la
médecine de ville
dans tous les cas ça lance un signal
alors je rebondis sur ce que disait
monsieur bizarre tout à l'heure à savoir
en fait le changement de changement de
perspective actuellement je pense en
effet que les gouvernements depuis en
fait une dizaine d'années ont pris
conscience qu'en effet on perd c'est en
fait de léguer aux chroniques et que
l'ambulatoire avait sa place autant en
fait que l'hospitalier sauf que
finalement ces changements se font à
très lentement très lentement on a mis
en place il ya sous en 2014-2015 laisser
pts les communautés professionnelles
territoire rural de santé qui tendent à
organiser sur les territoires de santé
les professionnels de santé libéraux
qu'ils soient d'ailleurs en fait
soignants qu'ils soient en fait médecins
etc
les maisons de santé
pluriprofessionnelle en effet sont une
des réponses apportées à cette crise en
fait dû normaliser leurs tanks et à
l'organisation en fait des médecins sur
le territoire
j'ajoute juste une chose concernant en
fait le choc d'accroître l'attractivité
dont parlait monsieur s'attache à tout à
l'heure le neurologue qui interpellé
monsieur macron il faut savoir en fait
que le gouvernement a quand même répondu
à cette demande en tous les cas d'autres
activités par un premier plan le plan
urgence à l'hôpital qui a été
malheureusement estimé enfin ils ont
débloqué une somme de 300 millions
d'euros alors que le collectif interroge
ans et les collectifs un terreau
hôpitaux attendait une somme de 4
milliards d'euros 4,4 pour cent de plus
tout à fait et ce qui correspond en fait
au delta entre les dépenses engagées
pour le collectif pour les différents
collectifs en tous les cas et les les
dépenses engagées dans ce que on voit
que entre les 300 millions d'euros et 4
milliards en fait que demander et
collectif
et bien en fait un gap assez énorme on
va continuer d'en parler et rester avec
nous on continue ce débat sur la crise
du secteur médical alors que le ministre
de la santé vient de déclencher le plan
blanc dans tous les
hôpitaux de france à cause du
coronavirus on en parle dans quelques
minutes
restez avec nous
[Musique]
l'arrivée de la solitaire ce qu'on peut
parler de révolution
techniquement oui on peut parler de
révolution est ce qu'on pourrait pas
réservé sa à des applications bien
précise plutôt que vouloir absolument le
mettre à disposition de tout le monde il
faut avoir en tête pour que pour chaque
génération il faut qu'elle soit
accompagnée d'un kill à l'application
ça veut dire développer une application
qui fait le boom est ce que on a bien
mesuré toute la dépense énergétique de
nouveaux terminaux de nouvelle
implantation de relais le futur de la
cinq cdc des systèmes de communication à
très très très haut débit suce moi enfin
télécharger un film plus vite
qu'est ce que ça va vous apporter les
craintes et c'est par manque
d'information est probablement un manque
de collaboration est ce que aujourd'hui
le monde entier a besoin de la ceinture
le football est richissime et le
football génère beaucoup d'argent donc
génère beaucoup de redistribution pour
les footballeurs des principaux sportif
et donc leur rémunération
mais à côté tous les sportifs et
l'immense majorité des sportifs de haut
niveau qui participent aux jeux
olympiques et participe à des
championnats du monde gagne très mal
leurs vies ne sont absolument pas la
compagnie ne sont pas aidés ne sont pas
soutenues et résultats que vous l'avez
dit 4 sur 10 gagnent moins de 500 euros
par mois donc je pense qu'il faudrait
réfléchir sur un dispositif vraiment
plus spécifique puisque le monde du
sport c'est une spécificité donc
peut-être tenté de rentrer de rentrer
dans sa pour pouvoir mieux accompagner
les sportifs de haut niveau est
considérée l'espoir un peu amateur comme
vous l'avez si bien dit elle athétisme
ou d'autres sports comme un métier on
parle de jeu pour le sport on parle de
loisirs de pratique de loisirs vraiment
d'amusement et de métier contraignant de
pénibilité pour le travail et ont donc
il serait logique d'accorder des aides
et des soutiens pour les travailleurs
est illogique de faire de même pour les
sportifs puisque il s'amuse
[Musique]
mais
pôle it mag la suite avec laurent alice
20 ce qui est de soignant à l'hôpital
tenon et membre du collectif s'interroge
ans frédéric bizarre économiste de la
santé et jean bernard gervais rédacteur
en chef du magazine en ligne
what's up doc une crise dans la crise
pour les hôpitaux publics en france
alors qu'il se prépare à une aggravation
de l'épidémie du couronne allié russe
les urgentistes et le personnel
hospitalier sont en surchauffe en
particulier dans les déserts médicaux
à près de 4 millions de français sont
concernés par ces difficultés d'accès
aux soins à katia technique 3,8 millions
de français vivent dans un désert
médical contre 2,5 millions en 2015
voilà ce que révèle un rapport de la
direction de la recherche des études de
l'évaluation et des statistiques portant
sur l'année 2018 les déserts médicaux
gagne du terrain même si la france forme
actuellement davantage de médecins
ils sont six mille cinq cents de moins
depuis 2010 et selon le conseil de
l'ordre
cette déperdition va se poursuivre
jusqu'en 2025 et l'accessibilité
géographique aux généralistes en france
a baissé de 3,3 pour cent entre 2015 et
2018 les zones les plus touchées sont
les territoires d'outre-mer le val de
loire et l'île de france
dans ces deux dernières régions le
nombre de généralistes a baissé de 4,2
et 5,8 pour cent entre 2015 et 2018
alors que le nombre d'habitants a
augmenté dans le même temps la cause de
ces déserts davantage de besoins de
soins pour un nombre moindre de médecin
à cause de leur départ en retraite qui
n'est pas compensée par les nouvelles
installations
la médecine générale attire moins les
étudiants et les jeunes médecins surtout
dans des zones moins attractive qui
comporte peu d'équipement et de commerce
et malgré les mesures mises en place
depuis plusieurs années la tendance à la
désertification ne s'inverse pas voilà
comment attirer d'ailleurs les médecins
frédéric bizarre on a parlé de ses
solutions alternatives en dans les
collectivités mais le problème c'est
qu'il faut aussi pouvoir les attirer ces
médecins qui ne sont pas forcément
qu'ils n'ont pas forcément envie d'aller
dans des zones
où il n'y a pas toutes les commodités
certains parlent de les salariés c'est
le cas notamment dans le centre val de
loire où 150 médecins vont être salarié
ce que c'est la solution
non d'abord moi je pense que la
réflexion sur les statuts en pensant le
salarié en parle quelquefois du libéral
hôpital public de mieux et du salariat
dans danville moi je ne crois pas du
tout que ce soit un problème de statut
la france a eu une force c'est qu'elle
elle a fait vivre en fait ces deux
statuts avec un hôpital public très fort
ce dans le réseau hospitalier et puis un
exercice libéral très fort en médecine
de ville bon on a vu que ça a plutôt
bien fonctionné
bon donc je pense que rendons attractif
à la fois l'exercice salarié et
l'exercice libéral et laissons les
soignants faire le choix de ce statut
c'est une théorie économique qui est
quand même très clair là dessus c'est
que ce n'est pas une question de statut
mais une question de régulation tout
dépend comment est ce que vous allez
réguler les hôpitaux publics
comment est ce que vous allez réguler
l'exercice libéral mais les deux sont
capables d'apporter un service public
parce que je voulais dire un mot sur le
la réflexion qui y avoir c'est que je
pense qu'il faut et il ya une chose qui
est très importante c'est pas que
l'hôpital public qu'il faut sauter c'est
qu'il faut sauver c'est le service
public de santé qui implique l'ensemble
des acteurs du système
mais c'est important parce que fait la
moitié des hôpitaux publics y sont en
déficit 1 je le précise on va voir les
chiffres et les capitaux internes et un
tiers d attirer des cliniques leçon
enfin le système il est malade les ehpad
aussi sur un plan comptable donc le le
système est en crise généralisée juste
là
l'étude qui avait été qui était qui a
été mentionnée est assez intéressant
d'abord elle est très récente donc on a
vraiment des chiffres récents on voit
que par rapport à l'accès si on se met
du côté de la population
la situation n'est pas encore si
dramatique que ça je le dis parce que si
on prend conscience et si on agit vite
là si c'est encore le temps d'agir
mais ce qui est vrai c'était très bien
dit par monsieur gervais c'est que vous
avez à peu près 50% des médecins
généralistes qui ont plus de 55 ans ils
vont partir normalement si on les pousse
pas à travailler jusqu'à 75 ans dans les
dix prochaines années à la retraite et
on forme péniblement 3500 médecins
généralistes bon et si vous savez la
crise de la médecine générale provoquent
la crise de l'hôpital parce que c'est la
première ligne comme vous avez pas assez
de médecins
la liste forcément les passions voir
l'hôpital alors qu'ils devraient traiter
en ville donc forcément là et ce qu'ils
avaient louis ii pour revenir sur
l'étude c'est que l'étude montrait
c'était votre propos dans la question
quand il ya quand même un facteur qui
est important c'est qu'on s'aperçoit que
là où vous avez des déserts médicaux et
déserts médicaux c'est quand la
population n'a pas accès dans l'année
plus de deux fois un médecin généraliste
d'accord la moyenne c'est à peu près
quatre fois en france bon et bien très
souvent on s'aperçoit qu'il ya c'est
aussi un désert de service public
je dis ça parce que on a souvent les
maires ruraux qui vont essayer qui sont
beaucoup pour l'obligation la coercition
en disant c'est un scandale j'ai pas
mais il faut qu'il s'aperçoive aussi
qu'il ya un problème de service public
et quand vous êtes médecin que vous
soyez salarié ou que vous soyez libéral
vous avez en général un conjoint ou une
conjointe et vous avez quand même besoin
que tout le monde travaille en 2020 vous
avez besoin qui est des services publics
s'est donc octroyé à l'école donc pour
conclure ce il ya un vrai problème
d'aménagement du territoire qu'il faut
prendre en compte aussi
alors vous disiez laissant le choix aux
médecins d'alexandre c'est là où ils
veulent mais il ya quand même un
problème de répartition jean bernard
gervais le salariat pour vous ce serait
une solution
alors si l'on en croit la nouvelle
génération de médecins what's up doc
étant en fait le journal des jeunes
médecins oui en effet le salarié
salariat les conditions de travail
agréables dont le salariat fait partie
pourrait être une solution en effet il
pouvoir en fait dans l'art de l'hôpital
public excusez moi mais le salariat
c'est pas cergy vraiment alors justement
concernant l'hôpital public il se trouve
qu auparavant il fut un temps où le
salariat et les médecins hospitaliers
avaient des conditions de travail alors
je veux pas dire idéal mais des
conditions de travail qui leur
permettait d'avoir en fait de ne pas se
plaindre en fait d'un salaire et de
revenus inférieurs à ce qu'ils auraient
pu toucher en fait dans le privé il
trouve qu'actuellement du fait en fait
de la pénurie de médecins
les médecins hospitaliers ont des
conditions de travail qui se dégradent
de jour en jour non seulement les
conditions de travail se dégradent mais
en plus les revenus qu'ils peuvent tirer
en fait de l'hôpital public ne sont pas
à la hauteur de ce qu'il pourrait
toucher à la clinique par exemple donc
on voit de plus en plus une amende aux
générations de médecins hospitaliers
vers la clinique lac erie prévenons les
conditions de travail
en effet le salariat c'est une chose
mais si elle est aussi le salarié est
accompagnée de conditions
de travail totalement catastrophique je
suis d'accord avec monsieur bizarre ça
ne va pas résoudre à faire il ya comme
toi hein c'est pas une affaire de statut
croyez-moi ça dépend comment est-ce que
vous réguler tout ça mais il ya une
étude qui a été faite que vous avez
publié je crois par les lys nika
syndicat des internes qui est
intéressante qui montrait qu'en fait au
bout de 3 au bout de cinq ans les deux
tiers des étudiants étaient plutôt
enclin à faire du libéral que ça qui
montrait que c'était de l'ordre de 70%
que donc il ya donc en fait c'est pas il
n'y a pas de crise que l'on fait d'abord
moi ces salariés de key public vous avez
un établissement public mais en ville
d'être salarié de qui verrait les
modèles danoise modèle suédois faisaient
pouvait être à l'est de la ville pouvait
être salarié d'une mutuelle voulait un
modèle mutualiste et que ce que l'on
voit le succès vote ce financement par
les complémentaires santé qui est quand
même très très très défaillant enfin
bref
donc soit on change de modèle mon point
c'est de dire il faut qu'on réinvente un
modèle à la française comme une fois qui
a ses piliers qui ont fonctionné
il n'y a pas de raison qu'ils
fonctionnent pas au 21e siècle si si on
les rend attractif
soit on change de modèle mais c'est à la
population de choisir on va vers un
modèle type al anglaise où vous êtes où
vous n'avez que vous avez les piliers
qui est le service national de santé
tout le monde est salarié tout le monde
et et fonctionner en ville comme à
l'hôpital
et puis vous tant que vous avez ça si la
population veut cela ce moment là il
faut aller vers ça mais là on est en
train un petit peu d'essayer de tordre
un peu notre modèle en disant 'tiens si
on pouvait garder en fait un système un
peu libérale mais en salariant les gens
savent de qui on sait pas non non il ya
une confusion très importante si vous
avez un chose donc moi je pensais pour
ça que aussi le modèle doit être
présenté moi personnellement je pense
qu'un modèle à la française a montré sa
supériorité mais sous réserve qu'on
adapte au renouveau en jeu et qu'on
renforce l'hôpital public ou renforcent
l'exercice libéral en ville experts tout
de même entre le salariat et
et le paiement à l'acte il ya quand même
en fait d'autres modes de rémunération
qui sont tentés et qui sont en fait
essayait d'user de tout ça tout ça veut
dire en fait qu'actuellement il ya quand
même des paiements ou forfaits et des
paiements à la qualité qui sont elles
qui tombe qui sont testés et que de plus
en plus le revenu par exemple rost ouais
c'est à dire alors que moi la qualité ça
alors parler de l'europe ce qu'on
appelle en fait l'europe qui est le
revenu en fait sur objectifs de santé
publique imaginons par exemple que dans
une patientèle on est en fait tel
pourcentage de personnes qui prennent
des génériques si jamais en fait on
passe de 50% à 70% et bien l'assurance
maladie va vous payer un forfait c'est
un peu leur offre et donc on a tout un
tas d'histoires canivez pour avoir de
prévention etc
donc c'est un aussi un financement
alternatif qui s ajoute en fait au
paiement à l'acte qui n'est pas en fait
du salariat mais qui est aussi une
alternative qui peut par exemple
satisfaire les médecins et les 501
points là dessus que c'est très
important ce que dit c'est gervais le
sujet de mode de paiement
si on veut accélérer la chute de
l'hôpital public il faut faire ce que
l'on prévoit de faire dans ma santé 2022
s'est passé au paiement à la performance
alors là vous êtes sûr que paiement la
performance c'est quoi c'est à dire
qu'on va vous payer
on va garder une tarification à l'acte
ne vous allez avoir une partie de cette
tarification qui va dépendre de votre
performance
c'est celle qu'on appelle value bets
caire c'est la santé basée sur la valeur
concept américain d' approche qui est un
concept purement de marchandises de
marchandisation de la santé est là
pourquoi ça va tuer l'hôpital public
c'est que l'hôpital public par
définition ne trie personnes et les
cliniques privées n'aime pas dire ça je
dis pas que les filles privées trie les
patients mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
de toute façon l'hôpital public doit
soigner
de la même façon toutes les patients ce
que font s'il est ce qui est fait dans
preglem en tout cas devant le public
à partir de là pour être performant il
ya une façon et les états unis ont
parfaitement démontré le modèle c'est
vous sélectionner les patients
c'est à dire que vous savez très bien un
médecin c'est très bien quelle passion a
plus de probabilités d'avoir des
complications des taux de
réhospitalisation élevée et qu'elle
existait avec la sélection donc ça c'est
vraiment la fausse bonne idée qui est de
dire en revanche il est évident que
l'évaluation de la qualité la prise en
compte davantage de la qualité des soins
à la fois
pour et par les patients pour et par les
soignants doivent fermer ça doit se
faire entre pairs s'ils voulaient cette
question là encore attention qui doit le
faire mais là je pense que les soignants
doivent prendre un dernier mot sur les
modes de paiement
en effet il faut diversifier les modes
de paiement
la tarification à l'acte le paiement à
l'acte il est adapté
c'est le moins mauvais il n'y a pas de
mode de paiement idéal mais c'est le
moins bon mais le pardon le moins
mauvais des modes de paiement pour ce
qui est du soins courants du soin qui
est répétitif du soin qui est programmé
à l'eau peut-être pour le reste ça
fonctionne pas il est clair que pour les
parcours de patients chroniques
il faut passer à un forfait c'est là
dessus les médecins libéraux l'exercice
cigale doivent faire leur mue et
d'accepter moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui
devrait y avoir autour de ça si on avait
vraiment fait la transformation du
modèle sans que cela remette en cause
quoi que ce soit d'exercice libéral il
devrait à peu près 50 à 60% de paiement
à l'acte
il va y avoir une partie du paiement au
forfait doit y avoir une paix m une
partie du père dans ce qu'on appelle la
capitation terre pour encourager aussi
pour qu'on s'occupe aussi des bien
portants
pourquoi il ya ce que ce que font très
bien bon mais ça ça doit se faire tout
en gardant l'indépendance des soignants
et ceux dont on peur donc là il faut il
faut travailler avec les acteurs
une situation qui est plus critique avec
le déclenchement du plan blanc qui a été
annoncé hier par olivier ferrand le plan
blanc donc qui concerne évidemment
l'épidémie de coronavirus et les
hôpitaux de france qui doivent s y
préparer écoutez le ministre
nous venons de décider pour l'ensemble
du territoire la mise sous sortent sous
tension de l'ensemble des établissements
de santé et médico sociaux qui date qui
déclencheront leur plan de mobilisation
interne qui correspond au démarrage de
leur plan blanc pour les hôpitaux et
pour les cliniques et le plan bleu pour
les ehpad et les autres mais
établissements médico sociaux
bien évidemment toutes les agences
régionales de santé sont déjà organisés
en cellule de crise
en lien avec tous les partenaires et
établissements nous avons augmenté le
nombre d'établissements de santé de
première et de seconde ligne
ils sont désormais 150 sur tout le
territoire national
et je rappelle que dans chaque
département il ya au moins
un établissement de santé capable
d'accueillir des patients de a à z on
voilà donc pour la déclaration d'olivier
vers ans qui a l'air de dire que le
dispositif est bien en place
alors qu'on sait que l'hôpital est en
crise laurent lille 1 ce qui vous fait
face déjà à des patients qui viennent
forcément à cause de ce coronavirus ça
complique encore davantage votre votre
tâche bien entendu déjà pour commencer
on doit gérer nos passions du quotidien
donc on a une activité qui quand même
régulière on est déjà sûr on est déjà
dépassée par les événements et en plus
de ça d'autres patients arrivent où on
doit les prendre en charge
mais d'une manière encore plus
particulière c'est à dire qu'on doit les
isolés dans une pièce et il ya un
professionnel qui doit être dédiée à ce
patient là pour le surveiller et pour
s'en occuper mais c'est très compliqué
plus de personnel il ya une demande de
personnel qui doit être encore plus
mobilisés sachant qu'on doit faire face
à un manque de personnel chronique à
l'hôpital public comment est ce qu'on
fait déjà pour gérer toute cette
situation
c'est là qu'ils allaient en tant que
ministre hier qu est ce que vous vous
êtes dit à l'hôpital alors avec mes
collègues je n'en ai pas parlé mais en
tout cas de mon côté personnel de ce
plan blanc pour moi ça va être très
compliqué à gérer
bien entendu je pense que le l'hôpital
public n'est pas encore prêt à faire
face à se piquer le tibet épidémique
pardon qui risque d'arriver et d'autant
que vous même vous êtes exposés au
risque de contamination de ce que rené
virus comment est-ce que vous gérez les
choses mais sur bas dans notre hôpital
on est en masque on met en masse on en
place par don de dérider des précautions
avec un port de masque chirurgical en
soi même ne protège pas le personnel
paramédical mais qui la protège les
autres personnes on devrait porter des
masques qu'on appelle et ffp2 vous en
avez on en a au compte gouttes
donc on a eu dû faire face à des vols de
matériel dans plusieurs services
donc au final le
ces masques sont données au compte
gouttes maintenant pour pour le
personnel et pour les patients à risque
aussi et certains sont placés en 14 n
j'imagine aussi on en a eu qui on a eu
des collègues qui étaient placés en 14
années qui pour certains le sont encore
et d'autres qui ont été rappelés parce
qu'ils ne sont asymptomatiques d'accord
donc intérêt à pied avant la halle à
l'intérieur pour l'inflation dans les 14
jours par manque de personnel j'imagine
qu'on les rapatrie plus tôt à l'hôpital
ce que ça forcément les règles à suivre
carlos ce plan blanc il est nécessaire
pour essayer de décentraliser un petit
peu la gestion de la crise c'est à dire
que il faut il faut que chaque
établissement mais mais aussi demain
chaque cabinet médical et là on a un
petit peu un retard à l'allumage que si
on m'avait manqué de kits de protection
à l'hôpital pour le moment il en manque
cruellement
on pourrait repasser il ya un vrai
problème d'anticipation et une crise ça
se gère avant la crise un support en
matière de préparation et on a rogné là
aussi sur les sur les budgets c'est
notre état il est très bon dans la
réaction mais il est nettement moins
performant dans l'anticipation on dit
que la la population française est pas
très tournés sur la prévention mais
c'est avant tout notre état et ça
j'espère parce que malheureusement on va
avoir des conséquences économiques c'est
pas le sujet du jour mais qui vont être
très très très importante pour cette
crise là tout simplement parce qu'elle
s'étend et elle va durer et donc on va
être un art déco j'espère que moi ça va
entraîner un choc parler de choc tout à
l'heure mais au moins un choc de
conscience qu'il faut vraiment qu'on
change 7,7 cette approche là juste pour
le le le plan blanc ce kit ce qui est
important on va passer en phase 3 dans
les prochains jours c'est qu'il ya un
transfert un peu de la responsabilité
qui est très étatique très centralisé à
une responsabilité très décentralisé à
l'échelle des établissements à l'échelle
des soignants je crois que c'est pas une
question j'entende l agence des agences
régionales de santé
ce jeu ne vous sentez qu'elle coordonne
mais c'est pas elle qui vont gérer
quelques les employeurs nommé le rôle
c'est normalement un rôle de pilotage
dans chaque région à la fois des soins
et de la santé publique de la logistique
avec une amie à elle très très
technocratique administrative mais c'est
pas le sujet du jour
ménard il faut vraiment tout un chacun
et les moyens
et à la fois les citoyens mais en tout
cas les soignants et les moyens
véritablement de gérer parce que c'est
eux qui vont être franc qui vont être au
front sachant que la particularité de la
phase qui arrive c'est que chacun
d'entre nous peut être est exposé et que
l'idée c'est que vous n'alliez pas à
l'hôpital comme vous le faites
aujourd'hui mais que vous alliez voir
votre médecin généraliste sous réserve
que vous ayez pas d un cas grave jean
bernard gervais cette psychose 1 qui
s'installe un petit peu un sans être
alarmiste bien sûr plus de personnes qui
se présentent à l'hôpital c'est en fait
oui oui bien sur wii qui se présentaient
un hôpital qui vont se présenter demain
de plus en plus en fait devant leur
médecin traitant en médecine de ville et
lesquels médecins en fait de ville
généralistes ne sont pas du tout équipés
vous parliez tout à l'heure en fait de
masques ffp2 qui était distribué au
compte gouttes dans les hôpitaux
et bien en fait en médecine de ville il
n'y a pas de masques ffp2 en tous les
cas il n'y a guère que des masques
simples chirurgicaux anti projections
c'est regrettable et comme le disait
tout à l'heure monsieur bizarre c'est
c'est encore une fois en fait une mesure
certainement fait d'économies puisque
lorsqu'on a connu en fait la crise du
h1n1 en 2011 il y avait encore des
réserves stratégiques de masques ffp2
qui ont été supprimés pour des raisons
tout simplement fait d'économie convainc
comment il imagine donc en effet une
petite psychose s'installe non seulement
en fait chez les patients mais aussi
chez les médecins et les médecins
généralistes en particulier qui eux sont
livrés à un peu l'inconnu et sans
protection
ouais on va on a très peu de temps
encore pour cette émission vous parlez
de médecine de ville
on pourrait en finir avec ces déserts
médicaux est ce que l'eau est finalement
le fait de mieux coordonner à la
médecine de ville avec l'hôpital peut
être aussi une des pistes pour éviter
éviter cette crise là ça va être un des
déterminants essentiels de la
refondation c'est d'arriver en effet
qu'il ya une parfaite coordination entre
les différents soignants comment est-ce
qu'on peut le faire il faut le faire à
partir des territoires dire qu'il faut
véritablement construire et là j'entends
des jamais parlé des communautés
professionnelles de territoire de santé
alors ça c'est quelque chose qui va dans
le bon sens mais c'est un tout petit pas
le problème c'est que et quand vous
restructurez il faut véritablement
mettre les choses en face donc là on a
mis des communautés en gros deux projets
mais aux gens qui avaient des projets
coûtent effet mettez-vous ensemble ils
vous allez monter un prêt mais ce n'est
pas le projet c'est l'ensemble du
système qu'il faut coordonner à
l'échelle des territoires avec un une
nouvelle gouvernance mais d'abord il
faut définir des territoires de santé on
parle du theater santé depuis 30 ans
mais ils sont pas définies on ne sait
pas ce que c'est qu'un territoire de
santé
d'accord il ya des groupes hospitaliers
territoire pour les hôpitaux
et puis il ya des territoires de
permanence de soins
et puis maintenant il ya des territoires
de communautés professionnelles
territoire enfin vous voyez que tout ça
n'a pas de sens il faut une unité
géographique à partir duquel on va
pouvoir travailler ce qui manque dans
tout ça dans ce qu'on a entendu quand
même c'est ce que viennent de sortir les
italiens ils viennent de ghislaine de
chiffrer pour 7 milliards et demi
le plan d'urgence économique dont 1
milliard pour tout de suite
embaucher 20 20 mille professionnels de
santé 5000 médecins je crois dix mille
infirmières et 5000 aides soignants ou
10000 est fourni en cinq mille
infirmières je suis plus sûr mais en
tout cas chiffré à un milliard d'euros
passe rien une urgence économie pour le
système de santé il ya une urgence
économique pour les personnes pour les
actifs qui pour ne pas qu'ils perdent de
salaire s'ils doivent rester chez eux
il ya une urgence économique pour les
entreprises pour qu'elles fassent et
puis il ya une urgence macro économiques
à prendre des décisions la banque
centrale en a pris mais il faut que les
états aussi suivent donc là où je pense
que ça va venir on peut faire confiance
à l'état français pour ça mais là il ya
une urgence économique au moins aussi
importante que jean sanitaire on va
écouter pour finir à nouveau jérôme
martinez président de l'udaf mails sur
justement là la démocratie sanitaire
c'est ce qu'il prône un changement de
gouvernance radical ecoutez-le attend
qu'on n'a pas changé véritablement la
gouvernance hospitalière on n'y arrivera
pas tant qu'on n'aura pas changer la
gouvernance du soin dans son ensemble on
n'arrivera pas tant qu'on ne donnera pas
la décision à ceux qui soignent
on n'y arrivera pas tant qu'on partagera
pas la gouvernance entre les patients et
les soignants et l'administration avec
même pouvoir n'y arrivera pas et on est
loin du compte là on a des paroles
certes on a une ouverture en dix ans les
deux secteurs doivent se rapprocher etc
mais si on ne donne pas les moyens de
cela les moyens ils sont à la fois
économique et ils sont aussi politiques
donner les moyens politiques encore une
fois c'est laisser les gens décider de
leur avenir et décider de l'avenir du
snems parce que ceux qui font le soin
sont largement décisionnaires de
celui-ci quoi en fait c'est juste rentré
dans une démocratie sanitaire mature et
ne pas dire juste en une démocratie
sanitaire alors qu'en fait c'est un
théâtre d'ombrés il n'y a que les
administratifs qui gouverne et les
autres de robbie
mais ça c'est fini voilà laurent l i20
ce qu'il y ait une réaction à ce qu'a
dit jérôme marty je le rejoins une
théocratie sanitaire c'est ça oui ça
serait une bonne chose si un peu le
personnel médical et paramédical été
entendu et surtout écoutés il pourrait
peut-être prendre des décisions ensemble
avec les administratifs
on peut voir que le personnel a
complètement été oubliés de chaque
décision qui a été prise depuis les 20
dernières années
pourtant on a pu dénoncer plusieurs fois
tout ce qui n'allait pas ça n'a jamais
été entendu par les gouvernements et par
les administratifs alors que les gens de
terrain je pense sont mieux son mieux
présent est habilité pour dire ce qui ne
va pas c'est vrai qu'il ya une absurdité
j'entends jean bernard gervais il reste
très peu de temps mais un médecin par
exemple ne peut pas choisir une prothèse
pour un patient
un modèle précis c'est celle
administratif qui décide pour lui alors
c'est ouais c'est peut-être alors c'est
oui c'est un peu ça ils dansaient vrai
qu'il y avait un changement fêtes de
pardies cma en 2009 lorsque la loi hpst
a été voté que finalement les
administratifs ont pris pouvoir alors je
simplifie les choses assure les médecins
c'est certain en matière en fait de
démocratie sanitaire je voulais finir en
fait sur à un point par exemple les cp t
elle j'ai évoqué tout à tout à l'heure
et ses communautés professionnelles
territorial de santé qui sont regroupe
en fait de médecins libéraux de
soignants d'infirmières libérales etc
à la base il était question en fait que
ce soit ces professionnels de santé qui
s'organise sur les territoires donc on
avait en fait qu outre ou là des
initiatives qui venait en fait des
médecins sauf que finalement on
s'aperçoit au fur et à mesure en fait
qu'on avance que ce sont les ars qui
définissent les cpds donc là encore une
fois on arrive sur une future
administration et sur l'administration
en fait du choix on attend de pouvoir
fictif ça va pouvoir fictif qu'on a un
il faut en effet je partage mais c'est
plus une démocratie sanitaire et sociale
c'est à dire qu'il faut avoir une vision
de démocratie participative
pourquoi elle parce qu'a dit jérôme
martinez à l'élévation aussi au coeur de
ce processus s'est enfin jeu on n'a pas
le temps les piquets mais il faut
comprendre que c'est le seul moyen que
le système soit efficace il faut à la
fois un état qui soit fort dans ses
fonctions régaliennes dans la définition
d'une stratégie dans la définition d'un
budget global et il faut une démocratie
participative qui soit forte
territorialement pour piloter le système
au quotidien voilà il faut arriver à ça
et pour c'est pour ça qu'il faut
véritablement penser ensemble
ce nouveau système avec une vraie
volonté politique est là il est un peu
de travail
merci beaucoup on en reparlera bien sûr
dans un prochain pôle it mag merci à
tous d'être venus débattre sur ce
plateau c'est la fin de cette émission
restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
si on chantait mais rioux bah tu dis
quoi
une chanson d'ado guercy réussi